what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking up with thor the god of
hammer storyline which is just concluded
so we're going to keep this going for
the next uh about six weeks or so um one
episode each week right we'll do this
what is today wednesday this was
supposed to go out yesterday on tuesday
but the miss marvel trailer drops we
ended up doing that instead so um from
tuesdays going forward is when we'll
have this coming out uh and it starts
off a little bit slow right that's one
of the things you guys probably know
just from like uh going through and
looking at like donnie kate's stories
they start off a little bit slow in the
first like issue or two and then it just
kind of blows up after that and this one
does exactly that it goes in after about
issue number two what this does here and
this is really kind of cool it's a
little bit of donnie kate's kind of
rewriting things in terms of like the
history of marvel not in a major
significant way but kind of in a smaller
way right one of the things he talks
about is the idea of elder gods now
elder gods have been depicted in
different ways over the course of marvel
comics i mean we know this just from our
coverage of four over the years right
jason aaron presented us with the idea
of the elder gods insofar as like gore
the god butcher and the different elder
gods that existed across different
worlds gods of love and gods of peace
and gods of golden girls just all
different kinds of stuff
all different kinds of gods and in fact
uh donnie kate's actually lists them off
here right like the black winter the god
tempest right the king in black the
phoenix now the god temp this is one of
those things that's really interesting
here because the god tempest was
introduced to us as basically the source
of thor's hammer right like why the
hammer is able to choose who gets to
wield it because the god tempest was at
one point a cosmic entity it was uh kind
of manifested as like this physical
storm that was raging across the cosmos
and ultimately odin and the storm fought
each other until such a point where odin
was able to take a piece of uru metal
and then trap the cosmic entity inside
that uru metal and then have a hammer
built out of it and that's really what
we're shown here right like the various
elder gods facing off against each other
right fighting that this led to worlds
smashing against each other and meteors
hitting earth and so on and so forth now
we could also look at this as a little
meta textual that the concept of like
elder gods fighting is sort of a uh end
comic representation of just the chaotic
nature of the universe right that like
sometimes things just happen almost sort
of like how you would look at uh at
primitive stories now in terms of like
the explanation of the world right like
the bashango people of central africa
and like the great god bomba and the
creation of all things right you know
that kind of stuff so again it can kind
of go either way it is marvel comics i
would say donnie case is coming at this
from a more literal perspective like
there were gods in space fighting each
other and then like when one of them hit
the other one with the world a piece of
that world broke off and then it crashed
on earth and killed the dinosaurs you
know like it seems pretty it seems it's
comics
[Laughter]
so you could probably just roll with it
but regardless over the years and the
way this is done is that over the years
the hammer of thor has been a central
focal point of not really even just thor
himself right mjolnir has been
significant in so far as its creation
and the role it plays within asgard it's
as much a symbol as it is a weapon being
used by thor now in a lot of ways it's
synonymous with thor it was synonymous
with thor when jane foster was using it
and is synonymous with thor now that
odin's son is using it it kind of goes
hand in hand it's like captain america
and his shield and so it's one of those
things where really odin's son kind of
recounts all this right thor talks about
all this stuff and says that like in the
twilight of things right before jane
foster quote unquote died and ended up
coming back as valkyrie that what
happened is of course in that fight
between her and the man god probably one
of the best villains ever and the
entirety of the thor mythos just this
unstoppable force of anger that just
destroys everything in his path that the
man gog had basically been chained up by
the hammer of thor and then when the
hammer was thrown into the sun the man
gog was taken with it now one of the
things we talked about at the end of
that this is something i want to kind of
you know kind of offer an aside here the
sun is not enough to kill the man gog
not at all
you know someone like odin could survive
the destruction of a sun and odin is
terrified of the man gog right the man
gog is basically this unstoppable force
there's no real way to kill it there's
no real way to i mean sure if you're
like a person who can alter reality you
can just phase him out of existence but
even then it's questionable because
marvel's always presented the man gog as
just the physical embodiment of hatred
right the people that hated odin because
odin eradicated their race that is
hatred and anger given a physical form
so the man gog will always return just
kind of you know until the universe ends
it'll always find a way back but
regardless the hammer of course ended up
returning and that's how thor ended up
getting his hands on it there's no
indication that man god came with it so
maybe man gog's still stuck in the sun
we're not really sure but over the
course of the entirety of donny kate's
run he's really been hitting on this
idea that for some reason or another
thor has is is able to lift his hammer
but seemingly so is everybody else right
now it's kind of turning things on its
head but also leaning in to the uh to
the the kind of pastiche that's been
going on recently right one of the big
big complaints that a lot of thor fans
have is that ever since the walt
simonson days and the days of beta ray
bill lifting uh lifting mjolnir that
word started out is like wow someone
else could lift the hammer of thor
that's crazy now it's business as usual
like hey are you telling a thor story
and you really want to get people just
to buy it have it on the cover that
someone else lifts his hammer and people
might buy it because you know it doesn't
really shock people anymore but it
stands a better chance and if they're
not
[Laughter]
than if nobody's lifting his hammer so
it's one of those things and i imagine
donnie cage the guy is no fool he's a
phenomenal writer it's cool to see him
lean into this right and almost kind of
offer this thing that it's like okay you
know what if it's really becoming this
sort of hallmark of the thor mythos that
like everybody can lift thor's hammer
then let's craft a story around it let's
make a story based on that right let's
answer this question that all these fans
have which is why is everybody able to
lift the hammer of thor and so what
odin's son does is he actually goes and
visits sif now remember heimdall's out
of the picture and with sif being the
sister of heimdall she's basically taken
his place so now she's the one that sees
everything and the question that he has
here is can you see my hammer and her
response is no i can't see where your
hammer is i can't see who has your
hammer i have no idea what's going on
here right all i know or at least all
you know is your hammer's gone and we
don't know where it is and so following
that this basically leads to us jumping
to what is in effect a kind of uh
gladiatorial ring now this is one of
those concepts that donnie case is
really experimenting on and really
experimenting with and in fact it looks
like the hand of one of the celestials
or at least the the head of the
celestial in nowhere but the way it's
described here is it said there is no
earthly translation for the arena before
you no common tongue that agrees on its
origin some claim it a remnant of a
long-lost civilization hunted down
dissected and scattered in the early
days of null's campaign of blood across
the stars some claim it to be sentient
somehow still alive its great fingers
moaning and curling in the empty
freezing wind of the abyss grasping in
the dark for a body that is long past
its reach crying out for years long dead
and death all can agree that it is a
place no man should ever know that to
see it to know it is to never sleep
again it's a place of testing the black
hand of god it's the pit right it's
where people go for whatever reason
where they basically end up getting
involved in this kind of gauntlet and
they fight each other now the funny
thing about this is that odin was
basically dropped off here now we don't
know if people can leave of their own
accord or if odin somebody just doesn't
have the power to do it on his own all
we know is that at the end of the
previous story arc that odin had
basically met with angela and the two of
them had left together and essentially
angela just left him here right and then
just took off and that was basically it
but thor arriving here on the scene is
really him meeting with odin as the
person who created the created milner
and saying i need your help to find this
hammer it's one of those funny things
though because seemingly everybody knows
that mjolnir is missing and that thor
doesn't have it right it's one of those
things because the hammer is so
significant in the cosmos and even thor
with the hammer is so significant it's
like captain america having no shield
you know it's like the silver surfer
having no surfboard people will notice
like they will realize that thor does
not have his hammer and because the two
go hand in hand together if for some
reason thor does not have his hammer
then it means it's either destroyed it's
somehow broken or just generally not
available to him and so that's how
everything has kind of been put together
as far as odin goes and all these
different guys and so the two of them
basically ended up traveling to
nadavalier now this is a really
important thing and the reason why this
happens is because thor asked the
question i do not know why you would
bring me to the dwarves i am not in need
of a weapon forced i need mjolnir
returning before it falls into ill hands
and the response of odin is the dwarves
can track their creations across the
stars if anybody can find your hammer it
would be them and it makes sense right
the dwarves are like the best smiths in
basically any of the realms essentially
in the universe if you're somebody out
there that wants to have a weapon made
and the dwarves under davalier will make
it for you you will have a weapon that
is virtually unstoppable right that is
essentially indestructible especially if
it's magically enchanted uber metal in
the way that thor's hammer is the issue
is that when they get there the elves
have all been destroyed right like
literally the elves of the davalier have
all been killed here and it's kind of
nuts because initially the idea was like
okay like apparently there's war in this
forge and that's when thor is like no
this was no war right like look at the
val raven right there's no blood on
their talons still on their perches
right it's impossible whatever it was
that happened here happened without
anybody realizing what was going on they
were caught by surprise these are the
birds that see all the the ravens of
odin like they see everything and so
it's one of those situations that's
that's why you can't like sneak into
nadavally right that's why like you know
black widow couldn't like dawn her
costume and say okay come on hawkeye
we're gonna sneak into the forge of
nadavalier and we are going to uh we're
going to steal from the dwarves right
that's that's not how this works that's
not how any of this works
right they see everybody coming from a
mile away but whoever this was was able
to avoid that not only that they were
killed instantaneously before they ever
had time to react not only that once
they actually get into the forge itself
any dwarves that resided in this forge
were killed and the forge itself was
completely destroyed seemingly the
ability to create another version of
mjolnir is gone and it's one of those
things that just totally baffles both
odin and thor they're like okay it's
like the dwarves are all dead and the
forge has been shattered how could this
possibly be done and the response of
odin is like look at them like look at
the bodies of these dwarves look at how
they've basically been crushed you've
wielded it for eons now if anyone knows
it would be you and the response of thor
is yes like i see it whoever it was that
killed these guys used my hammer to do
it they killed the dwarves using myoner
now i will say this once the perpetrator
is revealed it's
crazy with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace
you